- [Voiceover] So we
have an example exercise
from our Khan Academy exercises.
This is the decomposed fractions.
with denominators of 100.
Use the following number line
to complete the equation.
The equation says 26-hundredths
is equal to star-tenths
plus six-hundredths.
And they give us this number line
and on this number line--
Let's see, this is zero right over here,
zero-tenths, which is
the same thing as zero,
and it goes all the way to 26-hundredths.
Let's see if that makes sense.
Well, you see between
zero-tenth and one-tenth,
they split into 10 equal sections.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10.
So if you divide a tenth into tenths,
each of these is going to be 100.
A hundredth is one-tenth of a tenth.
So that's 100, 200, 300, 400,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10-hundredths,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19
20-hundredths.
21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26-hundredths.
So that's exactly what they wrote there.
So they say 26-hundredths,
which is this thing right over here,
is equal to star-tenths,
which is really what's
being depicted in magenta,
plus six-hundredths.
The six-hundredths is this
green right over here.
Adding the six-hundredths.
Adding one, two, three,
four, five, six-hundredths.
So what is this right over here?
This magenta or this pink arrow?
Well we could say that's 20-hundredths.
If you count it that's 10, 20-hundredths.
Or, you could see, well
that's just two-tenths.
So 26-hundredths is the same thing
as two-tenths plus six-hundredths.
And it gets you right over there.
So this right over here
is going to be two-tenths.